[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing a topic that's come up for
much debate over the years
how was it that albus dumbledore and
gaelic grindelwald were able to break
their blood pact and duel for many this
question would have initially come up
long ago after the release of the
deathly hallows novel nearly 15 years
ago in 2007
here harry potter fans were first
introduced to the idea that albus hasn't
always kept the most acceptable company
discovering that he was once close to
the dark wizard gellert grindelwald
i believe it is also in this book that
we learned that albus waited a
questionably long time before
challenging and defeating grindelwald
despite the incredibly dangerous threat
he posed to the wizarding world at large
that said he did finally challenge gelet
in 1945
besting him in a jewel that became most
infamous dumbledore's delay in dueling
grindelwald at first seems puzzling
however we now know for certain that
albus was unable to challenge
grindelwald due to an unbreakable blood
pact the two men made in their youth
this would have been when both wizards
were interested in pursuing the same
revolutionary cause to overthrow the
mughal population and rule over them
with magic
and so it's quite likely that they made
the pact to prevent any disagreements
getting in the way of achieving this
goal
in the event that one of the two wizards
decided against their vision
which of course dumbledore eventually
did
for those who may be unfamiliar a blood
pact is a theoretically unbreakable
magical agreement between two wizards
resulting in either party being unable
to harm the other this magically binding
contract was performed by blood being
drawn typically from the hand at which
point the two wizards would place their
palms against each other and state an
oath a drop of blood from each wizard
would rise above their interlocked hands
form as one and become enclosed in a
magical vial this vial would remain the
physical manifestation of the blood pact
at the end of fantastic beasts the
crimes of grindelwald we get to see the
physical manifestation of dumbledore and
grindelwald's pact a vial that
grindelwald keeps on his person at all
times despite doing so however
grindelwald loses this incredibly
valuable item as it's the only thing
preventing albus from being able to
attack him to none other than a niffler
a small magical creature who is simply
obsessed with shiny things this
particular niffler belonged to fantastic
beast's protagonist and ally of
dumbledore newt scamander
so thanks to the jewelry obsessed
niffler albus is reunited with the one
thing that if he can destroy it could
allow him to finally take down
grindelwald now it's important to note
here the dumbledore gains possession of
the blood-packed vial in 1927. however
we know that the infamous jewel between
albus and grindelwald doesn't occur
until 1945.
18 long years later we know that
eventually dumbledore is successful in
breaking the blood pact and challenging
grindelwald
but what we don't know is how he does it
or how long it takes him
it would be quite reasonable to assume
that perhaps it takes albus almost two
decades to crack a theoretically
unbreakable pact it had never been done
before that we know of
so it's not out of the question that it
could simply take time to break this
magically binding contract but my theory
takes a bit of a different perspective
i suspect that in the upcoming fantastic
beast film the secret of dumbledore we
will witness him break the blood pact or
at least get around it
you may think that this would be too
soon according to the timeline of when
dumbledore does in fact duel grindelwald
but hear me out firstly we have yet to
discover how much time has passed
between the crimes of grindelwald and
the secrets of dumbledore and based
solely on credence's new look i'd wager
that at least a few years have gone by
there are also several other clues
throughout the two trailers that a fair
bit of time has elapsed between films
first of all we have no indication of
where either tina or nagini is and if we
were to be picking up right where we
left off presumably there would be in at
least one of the previews however both
of these women are quite noticeably
absent secondly we see at least one new
face the school teacher as thesis
commander refers to her who seems to be
quite familiar to our group of
protagonists even if not to us this
character has likely joined newt and the
others in the time that has passed
between the films in my opinion i
believe that around 5 to 10 years have
gone by since the last film
this would bring us to the mid to late
1930s
then let's consider that the secrets of
dumbledore may take place over the
course of a year or so getting us that
much closer to 1945.
this would mean that if albus is able to
break the blood pact in this movie then
perhaps he would take the next few years
to plan a well-coordinated attack on
grindelwald and his empire
this of course brings us to the how of
it all
how does dumbledore break his blood pact
with grindelwald
well in the same way that we see
grindelwald attempt to use credence or
aurelius dumbledore if grindelwald is to
be believed to defeat albus i think mr
barebone will be the answer to
dumbledore beating grindelwald
grindelwald hand-picked credence as his
weapon of choice against albus for
seemingly two reasons number one
credence is an incredibly powerful
obscurus proven simply by the fact that
he has survived into young adulthood
while hosting an obscurial from
grindelwald's point of view the young
wizards raw rare magical power may be
the only thing strong enough to defeat
albus
number two if credence is in fact a
dumbledore aided by the power of a
phoenix he is also more likely to defeat
albus in a jewel than almost any other
wizard but if credence is actually
aurelius i think this relation may play
into how albus overcomes the blood pact
you see in the trailers we witness albus
and credence fighting in a street in the
first trailer it looks like an ordinary
although very exciting jewel between two
wizards credence's obscurial form makes
an appearance and at one point he shoots
jets of bright red light at albus who
seems to calmly deflect them with his
hand
in the second preview we see more of
this same fight most interestingly at
least to me is the view we're given of
this jewel when it looks as though the
world is flipping round upside down we
start with a shot of credence lying on
the ground and albus hand pressed
against the young wizard's chest an item
in dumbledore's hand lights up could it
be the vial it certainly doesn't look
like it's wand and our perspective
shifts as the scene inverts itself
okay i'm pretty sure the item in
dumbledore's hand is actually the
deluminator not the vial containing the
blood pact but i'd vouch that he does
have the vial on him and i have a theory
as to what dumbledore is doing here
could this bizarre scene indicate
dumbledore shifting the pact to credence
if credence truly is a member of the
dumbledore family he would of course
share the same blood as albus so if they
actually are related which we don't know
yet could it be possible the dumbledore
discovers a way to transfer this
magically binding blood contract to
another wizard with the same genes after
all if credent turns out to be albus's
long-lost brother aurelius would share
the same genetic makeup which perhaps
could be enough to fool the vial into
thinking one was the same as the other
so maybe dumbledore doesn't break the
unbreakable after all he simply removes
himself from it
now you may be thinking well if it turns
out to be possible that a blood pact
could be shifted to another member of
your family why wouldn't other witches
and wizards have attempted to do the
same why wouldn't albus simply ask his
brother aberforth to take on the pact in
his place so that he could go after
grindelwald well my theory is that the
process of transferring the pact is not
a particularly safe one from the looks
of it in the trailer creedence doesn't
seem to be feeling all that well as
dumbledore has crouched over him
so perhaps it is quite a risky thing to
do further to this point is the fact
that albus looks rather regretful as
he's doing whatever it is he's doing to
credence
so how would dumbledore know how to do
this well if we look at dumbledore's
history it's fairly apparent that he is
a talented wizard having achieved all
sorts of accolades by the time he was
just a young adult and it just so
happens that one of these accolades
pertains to blood having been credited
as discovering the 12 uses of dragon's
blood most of which have not been
revealed to us harry potter fans it
seems like dumbledore is a blood expert
particularly in the realm of its use and
so i don't think it's a stretch to say
the dumbledore's knowledge of blood or
perhaps even the use of dragon's blood
itself relates to the broken blood pact
with grindelwald
how dragon's blood specifically comes
into play here is not really something
i've begun to tackle yet but if you guys
want a video on it i'm open to giving it
a go
in any case if dumbledore is successful
in removing himself from the blood pact
with grindelwald in the upcoming movie i
don't think it'll be long before we see
the two duke it out
which brings us to the end of another
video what do you think will dumbledore
crack his blood pact with grindelwald
this film or will we only see him get
close do you think getting out of the
pact has anything to do with credence or
do you think my theory is mad let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
and as always if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to like it and subscribe to
the channel
until next time
things are not quite what they appear
[Music]